well Charles Dickens said it best it was
the best of times and it was the worst
of times and that is exactly the theme
that was Charles Dickens right yeah oh I
don't know don't ask me I think it was
that is exactly what 2017 has been for
the David Pakman show I just as were
getting into our sort sort of mid-year
early mid-year vacation I wanted to
review where we were in terms of 2017
and to begin with youtube views have
been crushing it in 2017 here is a chart
of YouTube views over time dating all
the way back to when the YouTube channel
started in September of 2009 and you can
see that most recently we have been
crushing it with a record februari and
March the dot that then goes down that's
because April is not completely over yet
so that's why that dot looks lower but
the YouTube channel has just been
crushing it getting to 15 million views
in a single month the podcast has also
been doing really well the audio podcast
monthly downloads the reason this only
goes back to early 2011 is that's when
we switch to our current podcast host
but of course the podcast has been
around longer just a meteoric rise in
the number of podcast downloads and that
is also awesome I hope you're not sick
of the winning yet no no no believe me
because there's a lot of losing going on
as well and that gets to what I call
image number three this is YouTube
earnings which as a result of the
YouTube advertiser boycott in April so
far that last though this is I believe a
week over week so this is recent weeks
those last two dots the last one is very
sad it's effectively zero we're
effectively not making any money on
YouTube now because of the YouTube
advertiser boycott and so even though
the show is bigger than ever we're
actually getting crushed when it comes
to revenue because YouTube represents
forty to fifty percent of our revenue so
hopefully we can turn the much larger
audience into alternative revenue
sources to make up for the YouTube
revenue and there's two main
ways that were doing that one is through
patreon you can go to
patreon.com/scishow we're now over a
thousand patrons this is a picture from
our campaign when we were at 642 this is
so easy to do you just go to
patreon.com/scishow Backman show you hit
the orange become a patron but you don't
have to know anything you don't have to
create any kind of a system for
accessing member content or anything
it's super easy you just say hey here's
a dollar a month or hey here's two
dollars a month and you're replacing the
lost revenue we estimate each YouTube
viewer would give us about 30 to 50
cents per month if they watched all of
our videos if we throw in a dollar Pat
you're making up for the revenue you you
would have provided anyway and say that
you already have a patreon account or
you don't think you'd have the time to
use the perks of membership right maybe
the right path for you absolutely now if
you want to become more involved with
the show directly you can also sign up
for membership at david pakman.com slash
membership and that gets you the
commercial free streams of the show the
bonus show the all-access pass all of
that stuff a lot of people are doing
this as well it depends on what's more
important to you and what I suggest is
do the forty percent discounted
membership by using the coupon code I
voted 17 so you'll get a yearly
membership for thirty-six bucks or a
monthly membership for three dollars and
sixty cents and then go to
patreon.com/scishow vat Pakman show and
throw in a dollar or two and you'll be
helping on both fronts so an awesome
2017 so far thanks to the audience a
not-so-good 2017 so far financially
thanks to youtube but hopefully we can
make some of that up